today i'm going to be speaking with
robert vitalis who is professor of
political science at the university of
pennsylvania and also
author of the book oil craft the myths
of scarcity and security
that haunt u.s energy policy um so great
to have you on i i think at the time of
a presidential transition where
there are questions about if and how
policy will change around oil it's a
it's a very timely conversation
thanks it's great to be here so i i
guess to start with
when you talk about oil craft or or the
trick
that is sometimes played with the topic
of oil like what is the big trick what's
the big misunderstanding
well the big misunderstanding is that
you don't have to do
anything special to guarantee access to
it especially during peace time
meaning there's a world market in oil
one just buys it that is how the
military gets its oil that is how
all domestic refiners get their oil so
all talk about need to use military
power to secure
access or against threats um uh are
pretty much uh uh untrue
and can you talk a little bit about why
so there's there's probably some people
who will hear you say that and they'll
say okay well
there's an aspect of that that makes
intuitive sense but at the same time
the world wouldn't necessarily grind to
a halt if access to a different
commodity like pork bellies were somehow
impacted it seems as though because so
much transportation depends on oil
so many products uh including products
that have plastic
come from oil and so many different
things it seems that
the implications are different even if
on paper we're talking about two
commodities why do you argue
that there is not really a difference
because
the the vision of um access somehow
being denied by some
uh crisis is also something that hasn't
existed in
uh in our lives so for instance right
now
access is being hindered in all sorts of
way
to oil supplies but we hardly think
about it what is the perfect example of
that
the united states government has
sanctions on various governments
that are oil producers uh venezuela on
the one hand
uh iran on the other the that that
hinders access
uh in in real ways but we don't talk
about it
instead what we imagine is some kind of
i don't know like
a disaster movie where all oil
uh all oil production collapses we we've
never had an experience like that
but we we generate constant a scary
scenarios
one of the global relationships
that uses oil as a justification
for being sort of a special relationship
or one that needs to be
treated differently is the u.s
relationship with saudi arabia
and sometimes if you step back it might
be sort of confusing given
the democratic values that so many
administrations have claimed to want to
spread around the world and in fact many
of the military conflicts based on
spreading those ideas
it would seem counter-intuitive that we
would have the relationship we do with
saudi arabia
which represents much of what we seek to
change in that region and elsewhere in
the world
but oil and a shared goal of stability
in the region
is often cited as as the explanation how
does your
uh perspective on oil modify how maybe
we should be thinking of that
relationship
well one that is correct oil is used
as the explanation for what we
ostensibly otherwise would not do
right so and you know basically that's
another
a scary scenario to uh that has
that have trip that has tricked people
in the past so americans who otherwise
would not think we have some kind of we
should be
uh so closely involved with saudi arabia
except
okay but we need their oil and and so we
have to kind of
swallow our pride or or not pursue our
more idealistic side and that's
fundamentally incorrect
as my favorite oil economist of the
1970s
uh said back then and it remains true
until now
this one thing saudi arabia has to do is
sell their oil on the world market the
one thing we
don't have to worry about is access to
oil from saudi arabia or anyone else has
has to worry about are there other um
relationships so you you mentioned
venezuela we know about the the
relationship with saudi arabia
are there other geopolitical alliances
or relationships
that that are important when it comes to
oil that are much
less discussed in media and that people
may not understand
the the role of well i think folks you
can just think about the us position
in the persian gulf generally not just
in saudi arabia but in bahrain where the
fifth fleet is located
uh in uh qatar in the emirates and
and so forth um we have this
understanding that we have to be in the
persian gulf
to protect access to oil and what i've
argued and what the military has said
time and time again
and other experts is that that is
incorrect and so the real question
should be
so what behind that behind the uh
a rationale of strategic access to oil
what do these regimes actually do for us
uh that that uh keep us so closely tied
to them
i i want to get to eventually in our
conversation some of the reasons why
we've not moved off of oil more quickly
but before addressing that because there
are so many geopolitical relationships
that are connected to oil
there are significant it would seem
diplomatic and foreign policy
implications that would that would rise
if indeed the u.s and the world were to
accelerate getting off of oil and
towards renewable energy
and and other types of energy sources is
that
intuition accurate in in a sense or
or or do you believe that there would
simply be new justifications given for
maintaining the status quo which now
oil is pointed to as the explanation i i
you know i i'm i uh you you shouldn't
trust professors to predict anything but
of course
that said i i lean toward your second uh
uh option there right other rationales
will be created to continue uh
uh to pursue the policies that we pursue
now
that whatever else they do have no
impact on act on access to oil we have a
perfect example of this the united
states
is has a has a large military presence
in the persian gulf
in the past weeks uh saudi oil
facilities or oil transport have been
uh uh uh bombed by ships
and and the us is unable to to
prevent the precise kinds of uh threats
that we've
often think is at the heart of our
military presence there
but does the nate does the military want
to stay there
absolutely all else equal
um uh the military presence is of
benefit to the military
um they've never been really uh behind
any kind of
a retreat from positions where they are
already secured
what would be the and again maybe i'm
asking for a prediction or maybe maybe
we have a reason to to think one way or
the other
if the excuse of oil were no longer
credible in terms of explaining a u.s
saudi relationship that doesn't seem to
make much sense for the reasons we
discussed earlier
what do you imagine would replace it as
the justification
well well whether it would work or not
okay whether americans would come to say
okay yes we have to do
we we have to accept uh our
ties to the saudis we have no other
choice well
one is a new one um this is the one
credit i give to muhammad bin salman the
de facto ruler
um which is
it's a plus on the side of israel and
those americans who really think
it's important that the saudis are part
of a coalition
with israel against iran right and you
notice in that discussion there's no
talk about oil the oil disappears
right and in fact we'd be better off uh
if iran was producing its oil
uh unhindered by the united states it's
of course
it's of course producing oil but it's
doing that with the assistance of china
at this point okay so when we think
about why we've not moved away from oil
more quickly we seem to have the
technological know-how to do it to a
greater degree than it has
has been done and there are all sorts of
explanations that are often given some
are more foreign policy related uh
including what you and i have been
talking about some claim that we simply
don't have the
efficiency in some of these alternatives
to oil to generate
the energy we need that while solar
panels are
improving and wind is improving we're
simply not there yet and there's a
debate about that and it seems that
it to great extent it's not true it's
part about political willingness
to do it but but maybe to some degree
we're not quite there there are other
explanations given as well in terms of
will it would damage this industry
well but it would prop this one up and
then you have to kind of balance whether
it would be a net job creator or or
destroyer
if you had to give us a general
assessment of why we've not moved away
from oil more quickly
what would it include uh political will
i think um uh uh
the obfuscating arguments of multiple
you know uh vested interests in this
process
you know i've watched this i i've
studied how these debates
took place in the 1970s during the
so-called energy crisis
and there was a lot of confusion out
there because um
spokespeople of different interests tend
to argue
uh uh their positions uh they tend to
exaggerate
you know the the significance or the or
the
or the importance or the security
threats to their various positions
so i think lack of political will yes
the technology is not completely there
yet but at the same time i've noticed
something
uh happening for the first time
which is um the oil industry itself
or at least the largest segments of the
oil industry the global
the global producers are arguing in fact
they are preparing for a
peak not supply which is how we used to
talk about it but peak demand
that in fact their predictions are oil
demand for oil will be declining over
you know the medium term etc so i think
something is happening
and what do they say would be the the
catalyst for those declines in demand
uh concerns about global warming uh
the environment and the uh uh uh
commit commitments on par i mean the
commitments of
various uh domestic groups to the fears
of what climate change mean
plus the tech plus the developments in
the technology
um you know that's what economists have
said at some point
oil will oil will simply become a wasted
asset that will remain in the ground
because technology will shift such that
um we can we we will have a better
energy source sources to rely on so
along those lines the the president uh
trump the the one that's still president
for a few more days
um he has said many times during his
rallies and during
various briefings even briefings
unrelated to energy as they often are
he has uttered this this phrase that we
are now energy independent
um first question is is that true
and then a second question is has
fracking impacted the u.s
energy picture in a significant enough
way
that it has separated us a little bit
from the geopolitical oil situation
okay uh great questions uh no we are not
energy independent because we live in a
world
it's one world market for oil all right
we believe you you know we have this
fiction we think that
domestic sources of supply is what the
country first relies on and then
and only then does it does it uh a turn
to exports that has never been true
number one number two even to the extent
that we are now producing more oil
through a hydraulic fracturing
than we had in the then then we've had
for a long time
the price of that oil depends on
uh events in the world market so there
is no way to stop
the what drives us most crazy in the day
day-to-day
the um uh uh volatility and prices of
oil
right so now we're all pretty
prices are down but we remember back
when barrels of oil were at 102.
well in the future we are not able to uh
uh uh put up walls against those
um price shocks unless we turn
to a kind of uh domestic politics that
we haven't seen in this country for
decades
which was which would be to create a new
protectionist regime
right not permit any uh uh not permit
any imports of oil
and rely completely on domestic
production
well that you know that's been a failure
in the past that's caused
all sorts of problems uh in the united
states and it's hard to imagine
returning to that now has frat has um
fracking
uh reduced our dependency
no because i i i it's just not the case
so
there's one there's an easy way to see
that we can look at our oil
import uh uh figures and um
they're our we still import oil right
because certain users
um prefer the uh their own refineries
are geared towards certain kinds of oil
and it's very difficult for them to
move away uh from the oil that they tend
to use let me give you one good example
that people
never think of yeah folks argued they
expected that with
uh hydraulic fracturing um we would not
any longer be dependent on saudi arabia
and and
imports from saudi arabia would decline
well that's not true
why people forget that saudi arabia
is itself a major refiner in the united
states the largest amount of saudi oil
coming to the united states is to
is to uh uh supply their own refineries
in the united states in the same way
that a global oil company like exxon
uh would do so setting up refineries in
various countries
in order to have guaranteed markets for
their crude etc
so saudi arabia continues to import
saudi arabian oil into saudi refineries
in the united states uh real quick the
last thing i wanted to touch on
and and my my expectation is your
commentary on this would be more
geopolitical than technological but i'm
glad to hear your thoughts either way
there are folks on the left who are
sometimes divided over the role of
new nuclear capacity and technology uh
in it as a possible bridge from the
current paradigm
to renewables and there are some who
don't like the the sort of um
uh risk of nuclear while the more
nuclear engineers i talk to the more
they say you know that those
risks are really based on 40 50 year old
technology which is not what would be
used if new nuclear was put online so
i'm sort of open to the idea
of new nuclear as a bridge my concern is
that practically because it takes a
while to bring that capacity on
it seems it would be difficult to commit
to it merely being a bridge
what is your sort of thought about new
nuclear as as
and its role well i think i your your
vision of that is is mine it's i think
is
is the correct one um and also the
what doesn't often get talked about is
the fact that
those new nuclear plants would be
subsidized
by the by government in one form or
another
right it's very hard to do it
economically now without subsidies so
you can imagine
another new you know industry uh seeking
pursue you know
seeking those subsidies in order to in
order to uh uh uh
get new plants uh uh uh operational
um you know the text i read on this
question
the debate is still open i've seen i've
seen books you know by
actually old friends of mine from
graduate school who've argued this is
this is the only real way forward
especially if what we care about is
generating electricity
for the millions of people in india and
elsewhere that still
have no electricity renewals
[Music]
that folks need around the world and
nuclear is the way to do that but i've
also seen
technologists challenge challenge that
claim so
i think what we're going to see is i
mean i i can't resolve that
right what we're going to see is more
fights around that question and it's
certainly
there is certainly a uh visceral
uh argument against it on the part of
the left and i think that goes back to
you know back to the 70s to uh chernobyl
to three mile island uh and so forth to
no nukes there was a
there were the concerts back then right
and the left is
i'm i'm with you on this the left seems
more or less committed to the idea of
green new deal renewables uh uh
supporting fossil fuels or any other
kind of mega industry
at the same time yep uh i uh an issue of
critical importance and one maybe to
expand on uh
in in the future we've been speaking
with robert vitalis who's a professor of
political science at the university of
pennsylvania
also author of the book oil craft the
myths of scarcity and security
that haunt u.s energy policy thanks so
much for your time today
and take good care